[Music]
food just slides off nonstick cookware's
remarkably slippery surface
in 1938 an american chemist was
experimenting with refrigeration gases
a waxy substance formed years later when
bonded to cookware it gained a non-stick
reputation
[Music]
when it's time to fry using a non-stick
pan averts a messy situation
the non-stick coating is one of the
slipperiest solid materials on earth
called
polytetrafluoroethylene the name is a
bit of a mouthful but the appeal is
simple
food won't get stuck on this non-stick
surface
to make the aluminum pan they use 70
percent raw material and 30 leftovers
from prior production of pots and pans
they fire it to a molten state and
filter it to remove contaminants
the liquid aluminum flows into vertical
rectangular molds
a jacket of water around the molds cools
the aluminum to take it from a liquid to
a solid
a crane extracts the cast slabs
they're heading to a heating chamber to
soften the slabs
this will allow the metal to be shaped
and formed
a saw slices the slabs in two and trims
the ends
more blades scrape the top and bottom to
remove impurities
a conveyor repeatedly feeds the shorter
slabs to heated rollers
guides at the side maintain the width
while the rollers compress the aluminum
taking the thickness down to about two
tenths of an inch
the rolling also elongates the slab
substantially it starts out at six and a
half feet long and after a few minutes
of rolling it's been stretched to well
over 100 yards
pizza cutter style blades trim the edges
of the aluminum sheet
another roller winds the aluminum into a
big coil
they then unwind it and squeeze the
aluminum to flatten it
machinery now pulls the long aluminum
sheet forward to a 132 ton punch press
this powerful press forces the metal
around a frying pan shaped dye and then
punches out the shape
the freshly formed aluminum frying pan
falls onto a conveyor below
the leftover aluminum will be used to
make new frying pans
the pans now ride a conveyor through a
washing station where they're cleaned
and then treated with sodium hydroxide
this opens the pores of the metal to
allow an enamel coating to stick to the
outside and the non-stick finish to
adhere to the inside
a worker inspects the pans and places
them upside down on spray fixtures
it's a tight fit to shield the inside
from the enamel spray that comes next
the pan spin on the fixtures and twirl
by the spray nozzles for an even
application of enamel to the exterior of
the pans
a clear glossy coat follows
the frying pans transfer to a dryer
conveyor the hot air pulls out water
from the enamel coating and the color
goes from gray to chalky white
an automated squeegee silk screens the
company's name and other information
onto the pan bottoms
they now enter a long curing oven heated
to 1040 degrees fahrenheit
the cure toughens the enamel deepens the
color so it turns gray again and it adds
gloss
a suction device picks up the pan and
turns it around for the inside coatings
a sprayer applies a special primer that
will make the non-stick coating adhere
to the pan
it then applies the non-stick coating
the pans receive two layers of this
non-stick synthetic substance
the suctioning device releases the pan
and it lands upside down
then the pans journey through the oven
again to cure the non-stick finish at
around 800 degrees fahrenheit
exit water rains down to cool the pans
and rinse off any contaminants
then they go through an infrared light
chamber to dry off
from a plain shell to a pan with an
enamel finish on the outside and a
non-stick coating on the inside the
transformation has taken just one hour
a worker now aims a laser and aligns it
with lettering on the bottom allowing
him to punch holes in a precise location
on the side of the pan he slides pins
into the holes and slots them through
holes in the handle fitting
using a ram he flattens the pins to
rivet the handle to the pan
now no matter what's cooking cleanup
should go smoothly
[Music]
you